THIS GAME AS DALLAS LED EARLY BY
8 AND HANDLED ALL THE EMOTION
EARLY ON.
THAT'S GOING TO BE A CLOSEOUT
GAME.
BIYOMBO TRYING TO SLAM IT.
A CLOSEOUT GAME COMING UP WITH A
FOUL CALLED.
>> Reggie: AND NOW WORDS BETWEEN
BIYOMBO AND MARQUESE CHRISS.
>> Kevin: SO PHOENIX HAS WON
WHEN THEY PLAYED AT HOME.
DALLAS HAS WON WHEN THEY PLAYED
AT HOME.
>> Reggie: YEAH, THIS IS SETTING
UP TO BE --
>> Kevin: CHRISS IS GONE.
>> Reggie: A MASTERFUL GAME IN
GAME SIX.
>> Kevin: UH-OH.
CHRISS HAS GONE RUNNING IN TO
THE TUNNEL.
>> Reggie: I BELIEVE THEIR
LOCKER ROOM IS BACK THAT WAY.
>> Kevin: BUT IT LOOKS LIKE
THERE IS A LOT OF CONCERN.
>> Reggie: OH, HERE IS THE
QUESTION.
WAS BIYOMBO --
>> Kevin: BIYOMBO WAS WENT DOWN
THE SAME TUNNEL.
THAT'S WHY SECURITY IS RUNNING
DOWN THERE, IF WE CAN SHOW THAT.
SECURITY HAS RUN INTO THE TUNNEL
BECAUSE BOTH PLAYERS -- WERE
HEADING DOWN THE SAME TUNNEL.
>> Kevin: YES.
>> Reggie: THE LOCKER ROOMS FOR
THE SUNS IS BEHIND THEIR BENCH.
AND THAT'S THE CONCERN.
NOW CHRISS IS BACK ON THE FLOOR
HERE.
>> Kevin: AND NOW CHRISS IS
GOING OUT ANOTHER WAY, LEAVING
THE FLOOR, IN BACK OF THE BENCH.
>> Reggie: HERE'S THE THING.
THEY DIDN'T WANT SOMETHING TO
ESCALATE IN THE BACK.
I THINK IN YEARS PAST WE SAW
THAT WITH A DOUG CHRISTIE AND A
RICK FOX, REMEMBER WHEN THEY RAN
INTO THE BACK?
>> Kevin: THERE IS BIYOMBO.
YOU CAN SEE BIYOMBO IN THE
DISTANCE.
AND SOME VERY ALERT -- THAT'S
SMART BY THE SECURITY PERSONNEL
FOR BOTH TEAMS.
>> Kevin: